GREATEST MOMENTS HERE AT PEBBLE
BEACH.
FIRST UP, THOUGH, PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAYING HE KNOWS IRAN IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR A RECENT SERIES
OF TANKER ATTACKS AND HIS
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT PROVIDING
WHAT IT SAYS IS VIDEO EVIDENCE.
CORRESPONDENT, KEVIN CORKE, IS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE TO SHOW US
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> EVENING, BRET.
WHAT IT PURPORTS TO SHOW, IF
IT'S ACCURATE, THE IRANIANS ARE
BEHIND A SERIES OF ATTACKS IN
THE REGION.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU.
>> Reporter: A HAPPY 73rd
BIRTHDAY SERENADE FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHILE HIS ATTENTION IN THE ROSE
GARDEN WAS ON DOMESTIC POLICY,
EARLIER, HE TOOK -- ABOUT IRAN'S
BEHAVIOR.
>> ONE OF THE MINES DIDN'T
EXPLODE AND IT HAS IRAN WRITTEN
ALL OVER IT.
>> Reporter: WHAT IRAN DID, THE
PRESIDENT SURMISED, WAS ATTACK
OIL TANKERS THIS WEEK.
FOOTAGE SHOWING THEM ATTEMPTING
TO REMOVE UNEXPLODED EVIDENCE
FROM A TANKER.
>> THEY DIDN'T WANT THE EVIDENCE
LEFT BEHIND.
THEY DON'T KNOW WE HAVE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DETECT IN THE DARK
THAT WORK WELL.
>> Reporter: THE FOREIGN
MINISTER SAID THIS WAS PROOF
THAT THE U.S. HAS SABOTAGED
DIPLOMACY.
THIS INCIDENT COMES A MONTH
AFTER FOUR OIL TANKERS WERE
DAMAGED IN ATTACKS THAT THE FRUM
ADMI
-- TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BLAMED
ON IRAN.
>> WE HAD 14 DIFFERENT SITES OF
CONFLICT.
THEY WERE IN CHARGE OF EVERY
SINGLE PLACE.
THEY REALLY ARE.
THEY ARE A NATION OF TERROR.
THEY HAVE CHANGED A LOT SINCE I
HAVE BEEN PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: WHILE SOME HAVE
SUGGESTED CONTINUED IRANIAN
AGGRESSION COULD HASTEN THE
DRUMBEAT TOWARD WAR, PRESIDENT
TRUMP TOLD FOX NEWS THAT THANKS
TO HIS OUTREACH TOWARDS KIM
JONG-UN, THE U.S. AVERTED A WAR
WITH NORTH KOREA.
>> THE PAPERS COULDN'T BELIEVE
WHEN WE HAD THE FIRST MEETING.
THEY COULDN'T BELIEVE WHEN WE
HAD THE SECOND.
WE NEVER HAD MEETINGS.
IF I WASN'T PRESIDENT, YOU WOULD
RIGHT NOW BE IN A MAJOR WAR WITH
NORTH KOREA.
>> Reporter: STILL, A WAR OF
ANOTHER KIND, A TRADE WORE WITH
CHINA, THEY CONTINUE TO WORRY
INVESTIGATORS ACROSS THE GLOBE.
WITH THE G-20 MEETINGS SET FOR
LATER THIS MONTH, THE PRESIDENT
SHOWED LITTLE INTEREST IN
CHANGING COURSE TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH BEIJING.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IF HE SHOWS UP, GOOD.
IF HE DOESN'T, IN THE MEANTIME
WE ARE TAKING IN BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A MONTH FROM CHINA.
EVENTUALLY, THEY ARE GOING TO
MAKE A DEAL.
>> Reporter: THE PRESIDENT SAID
THERE IS NO WAY HE IS GOING TO
FIRE KELLYANNE CONWAY, COUNSELOR
TO THE PRESIDENT, DESPITE A
RECOMMENDATION FROM A GOVERNMENT